I've ever seen coughing here today I'm
gonna update you on my sort of extreme
language learning where I'm trying to
learn three languages at the same time
remember if you like these videos please
subscribe so I said that I would over
the next nine months try to study three
languages at the same time I Arabic
Persian and Turkish and I also said that
I would try to create a hundred links on
link that is to save a hundred new words
every day in each of those three
languages so how am i doing well I am
missing the odd day I have to confess I
tried very hard to do it every single
day but it's just not possible you know
friends visiting and playing golf lot of
the time it's just not possible to do it
every day but pretty close I think I'm
still last couple of days I was managing
to do it again in each of the three
languages second point is you know I
have my moods where I'm more interested
in Turkish or more interested in Persian
but right now I'm more interested in
Arabic and I can explain why it started
because as so often happens in my
language journey my wife was watching an
Egyptian series on Netflix so I tried to
listen to the Egyptian Arabic and I
couldn't understand just about anything
I mean I got the odd word here and there
but by-and-large didn't understand it so
I said that's not very good so I went
the Netflix and I tried to go through
you know frame-by-frame and the
subtitles on Netflix are in standard
Arabic but as I looked at it the
Standard Arabic didn't really match what
people were saying so that wasn't very
good so then I went on the internet and
I said I may as well learn Egyptian
Arabic so I you know surfed around and I
found this wonderful collection
material in Egyptian Arabic put out by a
website called lingual ISM and I'll
leave a link here in the description box
and they had their series one called
Egyptian Arabic voices one was called
Egyptian Arabic Diaries consisted of
random people talking about themselves
with transcript which is of course ideal
for link and the other explanations and
exercises so I got in touch with the
people who put this out and we are in
conversation now to make this available
that link in the new year secret by the
way the library and the content section
will be revamped and it'll be easier to
find things and it'll be easier to
feature some of this wonderful material
so Mathew over lingual ism has agreed to
make his wonderful series both in
Egyptian Arabic and in Levantine and in
Syrian Arabic available at link now I
looked into our librarian Lincoln I saw
them we didn't have we had a few things
in Egyptian Arabic that didn't really
appeal to me but we had the many stories
in Levantine Arabic so I for the last
five days I've been doing the mini
stories I think in Levantine Arabic come
up to about lesson number 30 and of
course as you start listening to it you
realize first of all that love and Deen
Arabic is closer to Egyptian Arabic than
it is to Standard Arabic but second of
all the more I get into it and the more
I listen and read the more it all seems
one language now there is after all you
are telling yourself this is a word this
is a Levantine Arabic word it's just
Arabic after a while just comes in as
meaning so I am very much encouraged to
become familiar with the different
variants of Arabic as part of my
exploration of the Arabic world so let's
just look at the
Arabic world where different forms of
Arabic are spoken and you know what what
those are boundaries are bearing in mind
that at least I have the impression and
some Arabic speakers will tell me I'm
wrong but I think someone who speaks
Levantine Arabic goes to Egypt and they
kind of can communicate in some mixture
of each other's dynamic that this is not
the case if you're out in Morocco or
Algeria I'm not sure what the situation
is in the Gulf in Abu Dhabi or in Iraq
but I think there's a high degree of
intelligibility within they at least the
Eastern Arabic dialects the sort of
conversational Arabic and of course
everyone is familiar with the Standard
Arabic because that's what's on radio
and television and so forth at least in
so far as you know political debates and
written in the newspapers and so forth
so I very much encourage that I did the
right thing by getting into Standard
Arabic but now I want to explore the
spoken varieties and just a little bit
of background of course what we call the
Arab world that's a bit of a misnomer
well it isn't a misnomer but we tend to
identify Arabic with Islam with the rise
of Islam out of Saudi Arabia which
spread over this vast area where it
brought the religion and it also brought
the language Arabic language because in
places like you know the Middle East say
the Levant Syria Iraq they spoke a local
language and even more so in Morocco
Algeria where they spoke up Berber
language and you know I did visit Petra
which is in Jordan with my wife and of
course the wonderful you know carvings
in the rocks and everything that we see
in there a very clever irrigation system
and so forth was created by a people
whom we would call Arabs but they spoke
Nabataean her
Oh Aramaic or some language which has
now been more or less you know absorbed
into or converted into the local form of
Arabic but undoubtedly I'm just guessing
I'm not a scholar that their form of
Arabic retains these influences and and
these people who live there I mean these
are people who have a tremendous
civilization even before Islam arrived
you know Mesopotamia is certainly cradle
of world civilizations or at least in
the Western world and I mean the the
people really what's today what is
Lebanon or Syria they created the
writing system that that is basically at
the core of the Latin alphabet the Greek
alphabet the Russian alphabet and not to
mention the Arabic writing system so
these are people with quite a history of
civilization culture prior to the
arrival of Islam and similarly you know
I was in Morocco I was in Fez and I was
in shuttle Island and they speak a
language that's even more difficult or
more different from Standard Arabic but
taxi drivers I met people I met in
restaurants there's a lady managing the
restaurant we were able to converse in
Standard Arabic so my desire now is that
I want to be able to understand as many
varieties of Arabic as possible and I
will speak some kind of corrupted
standard whatever if I happen to be an
11 on it but I should have that
opportunity I'll probably be influenced
by the way they're speaking but I want
to be able to understand not only in the
Standard Arabic but also these variants
of Arabic and even when I listen to my
podcast in Standard Arabic there are
always words that are interjected by the
speakers that come from their local
weather in the Egyptian or Syria
Araki form of arabic so i want i what we
said that my exploration of the Arabic
world is going to be long-term and it's
going to include standard Arabic but
it's also I'm going to include these
regional variations of Arabic and in the
new year we're going to have more and
more material at length in these
regional variations of Arabic I'm not
quite sure how we're going to do it
whether we leave it together as one
language or whether we have separate you
know language slots for loving teen
Syrian you know Egyptian or whatever or
maybe we just go Standard Arabic and
conversational Arabic and then group all
of these variations in the sort of
conversational Arabic language slot but
all of that is something to look forward
to in the new year and so I'm spending a
little more time now with Arabic still
trying to get in my hundred links a day
and Persian and and Turkish by the way
someone sent me a phenomenal resource
gosh Martha ma I was at a which has
these wonderful recordings of Persians
Iranians speaking to each other but
there are no transcripts so I'm trying
to figure out how I can get these
transcribed because my experience with
the automatic transcript service is kind
of a hit and miss it actually works
better in person than it doesn't Arabic
but it's not ideal the ideal would have
it be to have it properly transcribed
with punctuation if we can get some way
of doing it that's not too onerous and
if we can get permission from these
people to share it in the library I'm a
you know I'm certain we get permission
I'm gonna offer that but you're them and
if we do get it kind of scribe this
Persian material looks like this thing
again in our library but but the idea
and this is also what's behind these
Egyptian voices or Syrian voices is that
you just get a bunch of people
individuals talking about themselves
what they do their daily lives for five
or ten minutes they talk naturally and
they transcribe it so this way you are
getting the language but you're also
getting to know some of the real people
of that language and it's wonderful
learning material and we will have that
available in these various variants of
Arabic in link in the new year and if we
can figure out some way to describe the
Persian conversations we will do the
same and if there are other similar
sources please let me know anyway that's
all I got
thank you for listening bye for now
my name is Raja the column will be there
in France
[Music]
[Music]
so we have here four or five Berber and
person and to another one because you
have to get back to work
the most important thing is the food
here is delicious thanks a lot
Roger is a wonderful host okay I'm
interested in
[Music]
[Music]